foreign
a lot of people know Google for its
search tools and software like Android
but did you know that Google also
develops its own dedicated Hardware
Google makes its own chips no not the
potato ones but computer chips that we
use in our machine learning
supercomputers pixel phones Network
infrastructure and even in YouTube as
the video accelerators that uploaded
this video were designed and created
in-house at Google all these chips from
servers to supercomputers rely on Google
Cloud hi I'm lital Levy a product
marketing manager here at Google and
today we are discussing how Google's
ship design and Development Group
leverages Google cloud with me to tell
the story we have Matt doe and our son
frug Matt arsalan please introduce
yourselves hi my name is matto I'm an
engineering manager for the team that
builds the infrastructure that Google
uses to design and build chips this used
to be tightly integrated with Google's
internal software development
environment but we are now launching a
system that is entirely run on Google
Cloud hello I'm ursulin fatherhuk I run
alphabet Cloud which is a team within
Google Cloud our mission is to help
teams with alphabet on board onto Google
cloud in a safe frictionless and cost
effective manner we regularly work with
teams and businesses across all of
alphabet including Google Acquisitions
bets and other teams to help them Veil
themselves of the value and Innovation
cloud has to offer
over the past year our team has been
working closely with Google's chip
design and Development Group to migrate
them fully onto Google Cloud this
transformation has been incredible and
very satisfying to watch as the
organization has more than doubled their
performance and scale
Matt what would you say is the most
challenging aspect of building chips
in-house
the leading software design environment
but Hardware design has some specific
requirements we need to be able to run
third party tools and manage multiple
versions of Ip we have a very large
workloads and workloads that need to
scale massively which can make the
process quite challenging what was the
team using before Google Cloud before
Google Cloud we were using a traditional
standard data center implementation we
began with a single rack of computers
when the hardware team first started
over a decade ago which grew to our own
data center inside of Google as you can
imagine this brought many issues it was
incredibly expensive to maintain and
required constant costly upgrades as our
machine capacity needed to double every
year we weren't able to quickly ramp up
a new project because each one required
hiring new engineers and adding new
hardware we also had to hire people just
to manage and repair Legacy machines so
for example our Network file system had
performance issues and when it broke it
would take large workloads a week just
to get it back up and running again as a
result the shifted our priority away
from growth and innovation uh to towards
manual infrastructure management and
oversight wow that sounds incredibly
frustrating what happened next
in the interim before totally moving to
the cloud we were using Google's
internal software design environment and
would overflow into Cloud although this
method is reliable in the short term it
still wasn't a viable solution for us in
the long run and brought even more
challenges it took time to transfer the
workload over to cloud and Engineers
wouldn't have immediate access to the
results after execution additionally
Engineers also needed to have two
desktops constantly running one for
their design environment and the other
for the results in Cloud yikes that does
not sound fun I'm assuming that's when
you found the alphabet Cloud team and
reached out to our Salon uh yes exactly
this is the exact sort of scenario that
our team helps with uh so when we get a
call from Matt's team we knew our team
would be able to system the vibrating
fully onto Google cloud with alphabet
Cloud we started with their intake form
uh and that led to us doing a full
spectrum architectural needs assessment
the main need being reliable
infrastructure with features that
allowed us to scale massively yeah so
with the assessment we were able to
evaluate which Google cloud services
would be needed and quickly had a path
forward great so now with the plan ready
how did the actual migration go what
services did
the project a reality yeah so working
alongside Matt and his team we confirmed
they needed to use Google kubernetes
engine for the containers cloud storage
file store Cloud spanner bigquery and
Pub sub yeah through this collaboration
between my team and alphabet Cloud we're
able to move our workloads to gke once
we're in the cloud we took the
opportunity to identify a better machine
platform and one to C2 and quickly move
the workloads within just a week as a
result we could run jobs two times
faster faster than before it really was
remarkable to see this quick transition
in the old operating method this would
have been what a two-year program
exactly or rather we wouldn't have been
able to execute a move like this because
it's effectively building a new data
center between the general cost of that
along with the complexity and
productivity disruptions that it would
create we haven't even thought about
attempting it yet with Google Cloud we
can simply flip a switch uh come through
a couple of terraform switches and it
works immediately that's amazing so what
are the business benefits you've seen
since moving to Google Cloud it's the
night and day for instance the lead
times to provision new hardware has gone
from six months to just a few days as an
infrastructure team we have a small team
that can now manage a much bigger
footprint we're able to grow far more
quickly and if any bugs are found they
are debugged within hours which was not
previously possible it really has been
so gratifying watching the team reap the
benefits of the cloud
um Matt what are some examples of the
chips your team has launched since you
started using Google Cloud some examples
include the last two generations of the
tpus the networking chip we just
announced Aquila and the Argos VCU chip
which is used in YouTube for video
compression which is 20 to 33 times more
efficient than conventional CPUs wow
that's amazing looking into the future
what's in store for the team the team
well we're continuing to work closely
with chip development infrastructure
team to drive the improvements in Google
Cloud scheduling resource allocation
scaling
um we can say now that all Google chip
design projects are using Google Cloud
additionally we plan to open source our
processes so other chip manufacturers
can benefit from all the services we use
in Google Cloud specifically our bazel
build rules and regression systems uh
any predictions for how this will impact
the chip design space moving forward
with Google Cloud's Ai and data
capabilities we'll be able to anticipate
resource usage and use less resources as
a result compute design and development
will continue to improve in its
efficiency thanks Matt narcelon for
joining us if you're interested in
learning more about Google Cloud visit
cloud.google.com make sure to click the
like button if you enjoyed the video and
the Subscribe button to watch more
content like this
[Music]
thank you